on occasions like this he tends to get
treated like a rock star
but as Jeremy Corbyn arrived for day two
of the Labour Party conference the mood
music behind the scenes was far from
soothing Labor announced potentially
vote winning policies on Sunday
including scrapping charges for medical
prescriptions in England but they're
being overshadowed by divisions within
the shadow cabinet over brexit policy
Corbin was asked on national television
about his plan to negotiate a new brexit
deal and hold a referendum on it you get
the deal you want do you then come back
to the British people in a referendum
and sell that deal we put both fuse to
pressure people do they know the deal we
will put both views and say look this is
the best deal we could get this is the
remain and hopefully reform option these
are the choices before you the Labour
leadership slyness but when it comes to
formulating brexit policy ahead of a
general election it has to take into
account not just it overwhelmingly Pro
remain membership but the many labour
voters who backed leave in the
referendum particularly in northern
areas but some commentators say the
reality is different there's a great
line one Shadow Minister says my lay
believers are more labor than their
leave but my labour remains and will
remain than their labor so that risk
lots of MP such a local communities
thing is that by trying to please a
group of voters who are gonna stay with
labour whatever
members will voters will abandon labour
in their droves and you see from the
slight uptick the Lib Dems got from that
revoke policy last week that that is a
real and present danger even before
conference began there was an unexpected
push by Corbin loyalists to scrap the
role of deputy leader held by Tom Watson
who insists labor must adopt a clear
anti brexit stance Corbin intervened to
stop that move but on Monday conference
is set to vote on competing motions on
brexit policy of austerity and despite
the clear promises on things Britain's
care deeply about it's far from clear
labour can come up with a brexit stance
that will win over undecided voters if a
snap election is called Nadine Barber al
Jazeera Brighton